hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an Australian drama Thriller
film called escape from Pretoria
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie is based on a true story
during the late 1940s in South Africa
the government carried out a strict
racial segregation called apartheid this
system gave the whites more Privileges
and better jobs on the other hand the
black community was frowned upon
prohibited from entering upper class
areas and even massacred however after
Decades of Oppression they finally had
enough the black community formed a
movement called the African National
Party or the ANP their main agenda was
to stop the racial discrimination and
bring back Harmony to the country the
protagonist of the movie is Tim Jenkin
the whitest name of all a white activist
working for the ANP he is heading to a
crowded Market with two large bags in
his hands he drops one of them near a
trash can and the other one next to a
car then he signals his accomplice
Stephen Lee to initiate the plan it
turns out the bags contain explosives
which they plan to detonate right now
they immediately get to work and connect
some wires inside the bag as they walk
away two explosions occur but they are
are harmless however hundreds of
leaflets are scattered across the busy
Market they contain propaganda messages
against the apartheid government Jenkin
and Lee nervously try to flee the scene
but they are soon apprehended by the
cops later while awaiting prosecution
Jenkins wife sneaks into the room and
gives him some money which he may
require in prison she then wishes him
goodbye promising to always stay by his
side shortly after Jenkin heads to the
bathroom hides his money inside a Cigar
Case and shoves it inside him he is now
ready to face whatever comes his way
having cash on hand has got nothing on
having cash in ass at the court hearing
the judge berates Jenkins Lee for
apparently going against their own race
as a punishment Jenkin is sentenced to
12 years in prison as he manufactured
the bombs while Lee being an accomplice
is given eight years being dumb pays off
sometimes in the next scene the two are
escorted to the notorious Pretoria
prison which is exclusively made for
white criminals the warden receives them
at the entrance and immediately labels
them as traitors then he hands them over
to a strict prison officer meniere the
two are then taken inside the prison and
meniere explains the rules and
regulations of the place Jenkin
carefully looks around and notices the
automatic grill doors multiple barred
Gates and other security systems the
place looks impenetrable as impenetrable
as Jenkins ass after a while manier
takes them to their respective cells
which are reinforced by a grill door
followed by a full metal door that night
Jenkin is lost in his thoughts and he
barely gets any sleep the next morning
during breakfast time he wanders around
the canteen Hall until an old man named
Dennis Goldberg pulls him aside Dennis
is a senior political activist who is
also captured for protesting against the
apartheid currently he is serving four
life sentences soon Lee also joins them
and the three have an interesting
conversation about their respective
situations meanwhile a French Australian
prisoner Leonard is seen eavesdropping
on their conversation in the day during
exercise time Dennis briefs his new
friends about the prison's layout the
walls are 30 feet high the searchlights
cover every inch of the yard the barbed
fences are razor sharp and most
importantly there are snipers on the
roof 24 7. in short he advises them
against trying to escape as it is
virtually impossible Dennis also reveals
that many have attempted a prison break
in the past but all have failed after he
leaves Leonard approaches the two and
mentions that Dennis is always
discouraging new inmates from trying to
escape he however knows that it is very
much possible so Leonard proposes to
help them and in exchange he wants to be
included in their plan later Jenkin
brings out the Cigar Case containing the
money and sneaks it over to Dennis the
latter hides it inside some toothpaste
making sure it never falls into the
wrong hands and hopefully that
toothpaste never falls into the wrong
teeth 23 days have passed by and life
has started becoming normal for the boys
that night in his cell Jenkin lights up
a Matchstick and looks through the
keyhole in the grill gate trying to find
some flaw in it days pass by and Jenkin
becomes obsessed with finding a solution
then one one night an idea suddenly
strikes his mind he uses paper to
measure the depth of the keyhole and
also its length Jenkin then plans to use
wood to prepare a makeshift key the
following day in the shower he presents
the idea to his partners in crime
Leonard believes that it will never work
but the other two reassure him that it
will Jenkin proposes that he can get
wood from the workshop but first he
needs to observe the original keys later
at the canteen the guys initiate their
plan Leonard causes a commotion and when
manir arrives to check Jenkin has a good
look at the shape of the keys from that
day onwards he never misses an
opportunity to observe the keys whether
it be at the front yard or during the
morning assembly finally after days of
research he manages to draw a rough
draft on paper on the 74th day Jenkins
steals sandpaper and some wood from the
wood shop he puts them inside his coffee
thermos and stuffs a bunch of clothes so
that they don't rattle a while later
manier checks all the prisoners
thermoses one by one to see if they have
stolen anything when it's Jenkins turn
he freezes in fear and meniere notices
it right right away fortunately even
after a few good shakes he doesn't find
anything suspicious inside the thermos
and lets him go after the narrow Escape
Jenkin goes straight to his cell and
starts working on his first prototype he
chisels cuts and scrubs the wood until a
proper key is finally made he nervously
tries it on the door and to his Delight
it works but when Jenkin opens the grill
door his expression suddenly changes it
turns out the metal gate doesn't have a
keyhole on his side meaning he will have
to open it from the other end the next
morning Jenkin explains the situation to
his friends and mentions that they will
now have to make another key and somehow
find a way to open the second gate from
outside Leonard who has become ecstatic
with the success of their first plan is
completely on board in the following
days the three observe the keyhole to
the outdoor door and Jenkin tries making
a rough diagram of it fortunately after
weeks of hard work he successfully
creates another Wooden Key on the 100th
day the boys are mopping the hallway and
there are no guards around Jenkin uses
this opportunity to try out his new key
it is not as good as the first one so he
chisels it out to make it smoother the
key fits and the door opens much to
everyone's Joy however when Jenkin tries
to get it back out it breaks this causes
Panic among the boys and to make matters
worse a guard starts approaching the
hallway Jenkin tries his best to close
the lock but to no avail in the end he
only manages to get the broken piece out
right before the giant guard arrives in
the next scene after all prisoners go
inside their respective cells manir
arrives for a routine checkup he notices
Jenkins door locks sticking out but
doesn't think much of it and simply
closes the door inside Jenkin breathes a
sigh of relief on the 142nd day the
three Gather in a room and discuss how
to open the metal gate from the outside
Leonard suggests using a string but the
guys quickly dismiss it saying it cannot
be turned after a while Lee gazes at a
broom and an idea strikes his mind he
takes it outside and starts measuring
the distance from the window to the door
it is just a few few inches short the
following day while Jenkin is at the
workshop he notices a sewing machine he
quickly goes to his cell and develops a
similar mechanism which he then attaches
to the broom that night Jenkin places
The Wooden Key on top of the broom and
tries it out the plan works he
successfully manages to open the gate
however when he tries pulling it out the
key falls to the ground this nearly
gives Jenkin a heart attack but he
doesn't give up he sticks a chewing gum
on top of the broom and uses it to
retrieve the key back to his cell the
next morning during lunch time he
excitedly reveals to his friends how he
managed to open both of the gates Jenkin
now wants to inspect the other areas of
the prison so that they proceed to The
Next Step as all of this is happening
Dennis is keeping an eye on them he
again tells Jenkin to back out but the
latter has already made up his mind day
206 some new walls have been constructed
around the area but the routine Remains
the Same whenever out the three boys try
their best to inspect the surrounding
areas Jenkin even manages to strike up a
deal with the janitor he wants the
construction map of the prison and in
exchange he will provide soaps and
cigarettes the trade takes place at the
dumpsters unfortunately Jenkin manages
to conduct it without getting noticed
day 296 he and Leonard make dummies in
their bed before sneaking out of their
respective cells at night they carefully
climbed down the stairs until they reach
another Grill gate Jenkin chose this
night because the giant guard is on duty
because of his extremely obese body he
is slow and lazy despite this the boys
are nervous they are sweating profusely
with each passing second but luckily
they managed to open the gate just as
the giant guard gets up from his seat it
is time for his night Patrol hearing his
footsteps Jenkin and Leonard hide in the
storeroom and barely managed to get the
door closed once the giant is gone they
come out and continue with their plan
Jenkin manages to open one more door but
before he could try out another one Lee
coughs upstairs signaling that the giant
guard has finished his Patrol so Jenkin
and Leonard hide in the storeroom once
again on the way to his room the guard
notices the droplets of sweat on the
floor but he doesn't think much of it
after he leaves the boys head back
upstairs inside his cell an excited
Jenkin dismantles his keys in several
pieces and puts them inside his cup he
then puts the cup in his butt he then
goes to sleep hopeful that he can escape
and meet his beloved wife soon the next
morning the warden enters the cell and
wakes Jenkin up the latter has slept
past the morning alarm enraged the
warden asks him why he overslept but
Jenkin can only apologize so his cell is
given a proper search in the process the
cup on his shelf is knocked over and all
the wooden parts of the keys are
revealed the warden picks one of them up
and angrily asks what is this Jenkin who
is Frozen in fear nervously says that he
made it as a photo holder surprisingly
the warden buys it and leaves the room
but not before warning Jenkin to be more
careful next time that night our genius
protagonist has a panic attack making it
difficult for him to sleep however he
narrates that every difficult situation
teaches new things so from the next
morning on he starts hiding the keys in
different areas of the prison like
inside the Library the canteen and even
the dumpster one day he and his friends
also managed to steal civilian clothes
from the laundry all this while Jenkin
doesn't clean or brush his teeth hoping
that he would get an infection a few
weeks later he does get one and when
meniere takes him to the doctor he
inspects the automatic gate it is
Christmas Eve and the group has made all
the necessary preparations inside a room
they disclosed their elaborate plan to
Dennis and his friends they have made 39
keys of different shapes and sizes for
the 15 doors that they have to pass
however Dennis refuses to join them
claiming that even if they escape they
will have nowhere to go nonetheless he
returns the money to Jenkin hidden
inside a toothpaste roll later the
warden conducts a checkup of all the
cells including Jenkins he turns the
entire Place upside down but doesn't
find anything in the evening after all
the officers are gone Jenkin Leonard and
Lee get out of their cells and begin
their Escape Plan before leaving the
hallway Jenkin asks Dan one last time if
he wants to join them but again gets no
as a response following this the boys
gather all the keys that are hidden in
different corners of the prison they
then dress up in civilian clothes and
head downstairs suddenly they hear
footsteps it is the giant guard who is
slowly approaching them the boys quickly
hide inside the storeroom trembling in
fear as they hold the door soon the
guard arrives and notices the door
slightly shaking but before you can
inspect it the electricity goes off it
turns out Dennis has caused a short
circuit by destroying his light bulb he
and the others then start calling out
for the guard hoping to distract him the
plan works and the giant guard
reluctantly heads upstairs wasting no
time the three get out of the storeroom
and rush to the next door with the help
of their teamwork and the desire to
reunite with their families they managed
to open the doors one after another when
it is time for the automatic gate
Leonard swiftly goes to the admin room
and successfully opens it by pressing a
button everything is going as planned
and they ultimately reach the final door
the door which separates them from
freedom however to their horror none of
the keys work Panic sets in months of
planning and hard work have been foiled
by one single lock Jenkins suggests that
they go back to their cells but Leonard
is not ready to give up so easily he
brings out his chisel and starts
pounding the door lock this makes a lot
of noise and Jenkin becomes terrified
that they will be caught but to his
Delight the plan actually works Leonard
manages to break the lock and the door
finally opens the final obstacle is the
sniper on the tower however since the
boys are dressed in civilian clothes
they confidently head out no one
suspects them not even meniere who is
having a conversation with someone
nearby after the boys reach a safe
location they run until they reach the
city then they get inside a cab and ask
the driver to drop them off at the
border the latter hesitates at first
since they are white but when Jenkin
brings out his wad of cash he agrees
good thing he didn't know that Jenkin
printed that cash with his ass in this
way Jenkin Leonard and Lee finally
escape the prison after a year and a
half of captivity the next morning
manier finds out about the escape and
Rings the alarm but it's too late as he
wanders around helplessly Dennis and the
others start laughing in the final scene
the actual events that transpired after
the prison breaker revealed the largest
manhunted South African history ensued
but the fugitives were never caught they
crossed the border to Mozambique then
Tanzania and finally London where they
rejoined the ANC and continued their
protests against the apartheid in 1991
after more than a decade they were
pardoned on the other hand Dennis was
exonerated in 1985 and he finally
reunited with his wife and kids as for
Jenkin he never met his wife as by the
time he returned to South Africa she had
already passed away in 1992 the
apartheid fell and in 1994 Nelson
Mandela the leader of the ANC was
elected as the president of South Africa
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching